[Musique]
pour pouvoir voler lempire
où
il suffit d'y entrer comme chez soi
ils sont tellement fiers de ce qu'ils
sont
des rebuts d'autosatisfaction
qui ne peuvent même pas imaginer
que quelqu'un comme moi
réussissent à pénétrer chez eux
kassian andorre
lempire nous étrangle aussi lentement
qu'on n'y prête même plus attention
alors ma question c'est est-ce que tu
préfèrerais pas frapper un grand coup
pour un vrai résultat
j'ai besoin de tous les héros que je
peux trouver
pour le pire de tous
j'interpelle ça comme il veut appelons
ça une guerre
il ya de la sédition dans l'air monsieur
des poches des démons judicieux
tu es dans mes filets
et tu es un petit poisson
ou une grande voleuse
vous ramollissez
je ne veux ramolli pas
je lui ai caché depuis trop longtemps
tant qu'on me propose et sénatrices
ennuyeuse
une chance qu'on ne remarque pas mes
frais d'activités qu'elles sont hors
activité
voici le véritable visage de la
révolution
j'en ai assez de perdre